hello everyone and welcome to the first
round and the first game we'll be
showing from the opera euro rapid
tournament
it's a wesley show versus magnus carlsen
so the two world champions
and uh well magnus hasn't been doing all
that great
against wesley uh lately so let's see if
he
prepared something special for wesley
here with the black piece so this is the
first round
and the first name that we'll be showing
so uh without further ado let's check it
out it's quite an interesting game
so wesley with the white pieces opens
with e4
uh sorry about that and magnus replies
with c5 as he usually does against the
e4 we he goes for the sicilian defense
knight to f3 we have d6 and the bishop
to b5
with check going for the canal attack we
have bishop to d7
and captures captures and wesley of
course goes c4 and grabs hold of the d5
square we have knight to f6
knight to c3 and the g6 and there have
been so many games in this line that
both of them are still well within their
preparation now we have d4
captures captures and bishop to g7 by
magnus with
f3 uh strengthening d for pawn and here
uh wesley castles
uh magnus uh sorry f3 and the magnus
castles we have bishop to e3
and rook to c8 by magnus you might think
uh but why not develop the knight and
maybe bring this rook over to c8 uh
well the they decided that this room
belongs on c8 as this is still
uh within preparation and this is the
main line of this opening
so b3 defending the c4 pawn and now
knight to c6
we have castles by wesley and the queen
to b8 now magnus shifts the queen over
to a5 to put pressure on the knight here
as the bishop is also
slicing through this diagonal uh we have
queen to d2 wesley defends that and now
queen to a5 uh with rook after d1
and now knight to d7 magnus opens up the
the dark square bishop and now uh there
are a few games where rook 8 the c1 was
played but here we have knight d
to e2 and it is as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see how magnus deals with
this idea uh he goes a6
and we have a4 here controlling the b5
square we have e6 by magnus
and now rook a to b1 uh you can't go
uh grabbing pawns here because if you
capture them the knight here is just
hanging it's attacked twice so
not something you can do but we can show
it for example if bishop captures on c3
you go knight captures on c3 queen
captures on c3 and now queen captures on
d7
also the bishop on e3 hangs with check
so that whatever you do you're going to
be down a piece
so here rook 8 to b1 and now comes
rook to d8 now magnus wants to shift
this rook to d8 and this rook to c8 if
needed or maybe even b8
so bishop to g5 uh wesley forces the
move
the rook to move or rather asking magnus
are you interested in maybe playing
bishop to f6
and wesley would be very interested in
trading uh of his bishop for carlson's
very strong dark square bishop
so rook to e8 magnus decides against
this and now
bishop to f4 attacking the pawn here
and now knight d to e5 so now the pawn
is uh
defended for the moment uh well not to
defend it uh
right away because you could capture the
pawn but then you just allow
rooks to occupy the uh the d file and
then it's just gonna be pretty bad rook
to d6 and
where is the queen going there is no
square for this queen uh the queen is
just uh gonna
gonna be lost uh you might have some
counter chances with b4 but it's still
gonna be
uh it's still gonna be a very tricky
position uh for for
uh white for example if b4 you're gonna
capture on d6
capture on a5 and now rook captures on
d1
knight captures on d1 and now you can
either capture an a5 or maybe find a
different move but for example captures
and black has no worries in the world so
instead after knight dt5 we have
h3 by wesley and now rook 8
d8 now finally the rook belongs on the d
file at some point magnus wants to push
d5 as that's every sicilian player's
dream
king to h2 a nice prophylactic move by
wesley and now
queen to b4 uh we have bishop to g5
again attacking the rook
and now f6 so for the moment uh magnus
kicks wesley's bishop back but he has
weakened his structure a little bit by
playing this move f6
uh bishop to e3 and now knight to f7
so he's preparing to strike in the
center and here we have f4 by wesley
nicely controlling that knight and also
asking uh
what are what are your options here and
wesley is doing much better on the clock
since this is rapid they both start with
15 minutes on the clock
wesley has some 12 and a half minutes
here whereas magnus has nine so here
magnus strikes in with f5 and wesley
really starts
thinking here wesley took some i think
around
three minutes uh in this position to
figure out what's happening
as again there's a lot of pressure on
this knight and you have to be very
careful you don't really have
all that many active moves so you could
play something like uh
queen to c2 uh to simply prevent after
captures captures maybe wesley doesn't
want to allow a queen trade
but wesley goes uh for the absolute
strongest idea g
captures on f5 and now uh g captures an
f5 by magnus you could capture with the
e pawn but
with the g captures now you have a
really really massive center
and there's no good way for for white to
attack the black king
so here knight the d4 uh wesley offers a
trade of knights here and he wants to
exchange
carlson's dark square bishop as that
piece is just a monster
but now he allows this uh breakthrough
in the center and carlson does it he
pushes the
five so captures on d5 we have captures
on d5 and now bishop to g1 you do not
want to worry about this bishop all the
time
and now knight to d6 now carlson's
knight is coming to e4 and that's going
to be an excellent square for this
knight we have queen to d3 by wesley
now i'm pinning now the knight can move
and now knight to
e4 so again with a double attack on this
knight here and also this knight is
attacked three times so you have to be
very careful
so here we have knight seat the e2 and
now comes knight captures on d4 magnus
trades his knight for wesley is a very
active knight on d4
captures with bishop captures and now
bishop captures on d4 and now wesley has
to decide whether to trade queens with
queen captures
or rather offer a queen trade magnus can
always decline with queen to d6
but he decides to go for knight captures
on f5 and already he's putting some
pressure on this
f5 pawn so here uh magnus could
try and stir some trouble uh you do not
have knight f2
with the dysform because queen g3 check
just picks up the knight
and the other fork that's in the
position uh if you might uh
consider knight to c3 going after the
rooks again it's very very dangerous
because
queen captures an f5 and i'm just going
to show you the strongest line
because it's uh well it's very
interesting uh knight captures on b1
and now knight to e6 and already uh you
you you do not want the knight being so
close to your king especially with the
queen here
so we we'd see knights the c3 again
going after the
rook here uh for a moment you don't have
to worry about getting checkmated
uh there's uh uh on queen to g5 check
there's king uh sorry king to f7 with an
attack on the knight so
everything is fine for the moment but
after some trades here
captures captures and queen to g5 check
going after the rook we would see this
king of s7
queen capture 78 with scene uh queen
captures on f4 with
check king to h1 and now knight captures
on d1 but now queen captures with check
and you win back the knight king g7
let's say and now queen captures here
ends with white being up upon so uh
not the greatest idea here just going
after that
so here magnus played king to h8 instead
not going for some
uh cheap forks uh and now uh rook
beat the c1 now wesley wants to bring
the rook over to c7
as that is every every rook's dream we
have queen to d6
guarding against rook to c7 and now
queen to e3 by wesley
it's a very sneaky idea because the rook
is also on this uh
same file but uh you know it doesn't it
doesn't seem like uh the
black knight has all that many great
squares to jump to and
they are both on three and a half
minutes here so they have to play very
quickly
so here magnus goes for knight to g5
uh it's an interesting idea another idea
is maybe just shift all of your
attention to the g
pawn here but magnus goes for knights to
g5
he attacks the queen here but wesley
just moves it queen to f2
still keeping an eye on the f4 pawn
knight back to e4
again attacking the queen and now wesley
doesn't repeat he doesn't want to draw
here
wesley goes queen to h4 now what do you
do here
uh well he's gonna try rook to c2 he's
gonna play
the other rook to c1 and he wants to get
his rook to c7 and put some pressure on
carlson's h7 pawn
so rook to f8 as the f pawn is still
under attack the knight is attacking it
we have rooked the c2 now wesley will
start slowly mounting the pressure
and magnus doesn't want to play
something passive like rook to d7 to
take care of the c7 square
instead he goes queen to g6 you know
okay he's planning to bring the rook
here he's going to put a lot of pressure
on the g2 pawn and wesley needs to do
something about that but he says
uh best way to take care of that is by
activating my pieces as much as possible
so rook to c7 and rook to g8 now here
magnus is threatening checkmate and rook
to g1
uh wesley nicely defends it and now rook
to c8
forcing this rook to either capture the
rook or capture the pawn or just move
because magnus wants to get another
attacker into the game so wesley says
i'm pretty sure this is fine we're going
to capture on b7
rook captures and now magnus goes for
rook to c3
so what do you what do you play here uh
c2 is uh for the moment not available as
the knight
guards it but rook to c2 3 is also very
active
but now wesley goes for the only move
that gives uh
him the advantage and that is knight to
e6 he has to block the g
file with knight to g5 otherwise he's
just lost
so here the c2 square has been vacated
now magnus occupies it with rook to c2
and now comes knight to g5 and now it's
going to be very tricky
breaking through this uh this g file
so rook to g7 magnus offers a rook trade
now
rook b8 check we have rook g8 and now we
have
rook captures on g8 with check
interestingly wesley had the the
brilliant rook to b6 move here
which kind of shows that the queen
cannot capture you're going to get
checkmated but you could play ninth
captures and g5
uh sort of offer the queen here and
after rook captures and g6
knights to f3 with check forking the
king and queen
uh the uh the the pawn cannot capture
and after king g3
you're gonna recapture the queen and now
for example
rook captures king captures and king
captures on h4 we will get this position
where white is up upon but in a in
in a better position so wesley decides
against this he goes for rook captures
ng8 with check we have king captures
and now he goes for knight captures on
e4 with check
d captures and now king to h1
uh the he cannot push the jeep on as
this
uh rook is still pinning pinning it so
here he just plays king to h1
queen the e7 is also very very strong
queen to d8 check also very very strong
but wesley prefers king to h1
and here magnus goes king to g7 and
that's uh that's a king to g7 and that's
a very odd move to play
uh there were some other lines that you
you could try
but they are incredibly tricky to find
because
wesley's idea is g4 and here you could
you could try and trick white by playing
rook to d2 and now if white attempts
g4 then you play queen to c6 and you
don't have to worry about anything
now you're threatening to push the pawn
and open up a discovery the rook is
cutting off the white king from reaching
the second rank
and even if you open up a discovery here
with check uh you're just gonna play
king to f8 and there's nothing more for
whites to do here
all of the squares are covered here so
it's
perfectly fine and black is going to win
this however magnus played king to g7
here it's quite a weird move maybe maybe
he
was planning maybe for something else
maybe it was a muslim but i don't think
so i think he
he actually wanted to play this but now
this just runs into
g4 and now this is a pretty big threat
and there's there's not much you can do
about that so here magnus plays king to
f7
which kinda could have been played on
the previous move but uh you know
i don't know what what happened there g
captures on f5
queen captures and now rook to g5 and
now
you really don't have a good move
because the queen can no longer guard
the h7 pawn
once magnus moves the king it's just
over so here magnus goes on a checking
spree
he plays rook c1 check king g2 rook to
see to check king f1
rook c1 check king to e2 rook the c to
check and now
king the e1 by wesley and it was in this
position that magnus carlsen resigned in
the game
and the game one of this very nice
tournament goes to wesley so who starts
with a win against the world
rapid champion and uh yeah you don't
really have a
good good idea here because if you
continue checking for example
now you go rook rook to c1 with check
you're just going to get
kinked d2 attacking the rook and now
you're going to play
uh queen to c8 defending but it's not
enough now
to save the rook you have to give up the
game captures with
check king e6 and now it's just
checkmate queen h6 check
king wherever king 37 rook g7 check and
that's it king eight queen to h8 is
checkmate
and another thing after this king to e1
move uh even if you don't
start with something like this you could
play queen to d7
but it will not help you yes you've
avoided the the capture but now again
just queen captures with check king e6
rook the g6 check and that's it king d5
you're gonna capture with check king to
c5 and now let's say
queen d6 is checkmate so again a tough
uh tough start for magnus carlsen but a
great victory for wesley so in
round one of this very nice tournament
uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
we'll see what happens next as i'm
planning on covering the entire
tournament uh so we'll see if magnus
bounces back and
can wesley maintain such a uh such a
great playing style
uh so hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank three uh three two
oh one attazo saranpazzi zatarash
karpyak steven reich uh
says happy birthday to ayla c and wayne
hoy for contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day